last week you brought the heat I mean
last week last week people were taking
the clips of that of that interview and
they were posting it all around the
internet Tick Tock Twitter they were
like holy [ __ ] Texas Paul showed up with
a Blue Torch today because you did you
absolutely endorsed these people now we
were going to talk about something
originally but you're like no I want to
switch this fentanyl thing there's too
many mentions of this word fentanyl in
the uh debates last night uh yeah last
night watching the debates man it was
just frustrating as hell because it was
like watching you know carbon copy I
watched Mike Lee I watched Camp I
watched you know uh
Tim Ryan kicked the [ __ ] out of JD Vance
and every one of them it was the exact
same line Mexican drugs Mexican cartels
Mexican smuggling drugs across the
southern border we need a wall blah blah
blah it's almost trying to scare these
people uh of brown people it almost like
they're they're resurrecting the the
crime rape murderers some of them are
good people
seems like they're trying to revive that
[ __ ]
yeah it's a caravan's all over again
every election they do it every election
there's a caravan coming it's the same
[ __ ] it is it's and it's [ __ ]
and I brought receipts well here's here
is um
here's the tweet that I was referring to
of Lauren bobert now if anyone doesn't
know this bonehead is a current sitting
congresswoman which I don't know how
that's even possible we need to fix that
and you can fix that here in less in
three weeks you can fix that and really
honestly Colorado's got some early
voting um going on so you better get get
to it and get rid of this scumbag but
she tweets this dexus Paul she's in
Colorado she says this problem starts in
Texas then flows to the rest of our
nation
we have got to get a grip on this
fentanyl fuel crisis taking over our
country and she cites a Fox News article
okay and if anyone can read this here
I'm not going to read the article but
the headline here says Texas border
agencies keyword there over one million
in alleged fentanyl of course then it's
got the uh you know the scary little
picture here but it's got the CNN logo
on it you know they got it they gotta do
that too because it's the liberal media
bringing in this Fentanyl
um so give us give us your thoughts on
this but first thing
on the debates last night
do you do you think that this fentanyl
talk from the Republicans has effect
yeah it does because people don't the
border is a foreign area to
99.9999 of of Americans Even in our
border towns they make up such they're
small cities they're not large cities
um you know except for San Diego which
is the only real large city on the
border
um
people Americans don't know what the
southern border is they don't know that
almost the entire Southern border is
human-less
there's nothing there it is pure desert
it's it it
I mean if you go out if you get out in
New Mexico Arizona all that area in
there that entire part of the Southern
border there's not a human if you get
lost out there you're a dead man I'm
telling you there's nothing there
and people don't know that so it's easy
to tell them [ __ ] about it
especially if you make it a real scary
story about them Mexican people and them
drug cartels that's him doing it right
there when it's not it's [ __ ] Billy
Bob it's [ __ ] Billy Bob in the U.S
mail
that's exactly who's doing it wait wait
wait wait wait you're telling me
you're telling me that the United States
Postal Service
and other shipping organizations
as a country private organ private
business are shipping this stuff into
our country is that what you're saying
I'm telling you the DEA will tell you
the number one drug mule for fentanyl is
the United States mail service period
son of a [ __ ]
where is this being mailed from is it
being mailed from the drug cartels in
Mexico now it's being mailed from China
the same Labs that make it for made it
for the pharmaceutical companies China
back in 2019 uh because Trump's an idiot
and doesn't know that fentanyl actually
had a medical use uh insisted that China
uh if they wanted to smooth out our
trade agreements made fentanyl
completely illegal so the labs that were
making fentanyl for drug companies here
in the United States
uh by the way people your your drugs are
not made here they're made in China you
know they like to tell you about foreign
drugs being dangerous and don't buy
drugs from Canada because it's dangerous
but your drugs right here made in
[ __ ] China like everything else
but those labs said well we got to make
something so they uh China made the law
said you can't manufacture fentanyl
anymore so
they took all of the ingredients all the
precursors everything
manufacture those
they put them on Facebook for [ __ ]
Facebook I am not kidding the number one
seller of illicit fentanyl in this
country uses Facebook LinkedIn and
Twitter as his primary source of sales
then he puts it in the United States
Postal
envelope and mails it from China
and your people pick it up
right and it's so cheap to manufacture
he's he's even got a guarantee if they
find it we'll we'll mail you more
I'm not kidding I'm not even kidding
well you know some of the failed
Fentanyl
country and and by failed fentanyl
policy
I mean the actual [ __ ] truth is
Republicans they'll go on Fox News and
say if you touch fentanyl you'll die not
and people being none the wiser they've
taken probably taken fentanyl in their
life before and had no clue that they
have taken it they just don't know
because it is a prescription
also there's like a medical use like you
said for fentanyl where the hell do you
think it's a synthetic opioid right and
and it it's absolutely
ridiculous that they can go on live TV
just like Marsha Blackburn said this
morning on live TV that rich P that that
student debt relief is a gift to rich
people what a [ __ ] liar but she's the
same [ __ ] liar who supported the drug
companies with fentanyl
she supported the drug companies dumping
opioids into Tennessee communities and
destroying and that's exactly that's
exactly where this started from that's
exactly where this started from was the
opioid crisis that made that fat piece
of [ __ ] bastard Rush Limbaugh death
I don't know if you remember that I I
that was a happy day in my life when I
found out that [ __ ] did some
smoke so much oxy that he went deaf but
uh I celebrate that every year it's a
holiday in this house and Rush Limbaugh
death day is that what you know yeah
yeah
[ __ ] day we call it around here
you know you know I want to congratulate
I want to congratulate rushland ball for
being drug-free for so long it is uh
yeah we only had to die to do it right
the guy with the back right now the guy
with the back injury that used to golf
every day that that guy
you know he was taking he was taking all
that oxy cause he had a back injury we
have an Adderall shortage now and they
couldn't mention that because they're
they're King their King and Mussolini
Jesus is suffering from the Adderall
surge uh we got Gabe Sanchez here uh
Gabe are you keeping up with our
conversation I want to make sure you're
on track here I'm drawing the vent and
I'll talk yeah no I'm trying I'm just
trying to uh just I'm trying to get back
my old prescription for Adderall but
it's hard I can tell you that for a fact
it is hard
well you know I don't blame you I don't
blame you Texas Paul you were saying
that this is where it's all started is
is this yeah
you know everybody remembers the oxy
crisis right so they made that illegal
so a lot of people first thing they did
was they went to heroin
and we had a huge heroin crisis around
2010 if you remember everybody was
talking about heroin was just out of
control and you know that's one of the
great reasons we were in Afghanistan
because we could just take those poppy
fields out and yada yada yada yada
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
so we had a heroin crisis well people
don't realize heroin is actually a
pretty low-grade opioid it's not you
know oxy was much stronger than heroin
so to spice it up a little bit drug men
you know drug dealers started mixing
fentanyl with their heroin
and heroin users are like oh yeah baby
this is what we want
we want this and since you know as time
went on they just quit putting the
heroin in it and everybody started
smoking Fenton now they're smoking this
[ __ ] man they crush it and smoke it I'm
not even kidding I mean
but I'm telling you
there's a reason they're saying this one
it's the old Caravan [ __ ] again
blame it on Mexico
that's one aspect of it the other aspect
of it is they don't want this Trace back
to they cost this the Republicans and
their deal with the Devil with the
[ __ ] drug companies that allowed oxy
to be pumped all over our country you
know they were dumping it on veterans
veterans would come in and say man I
tell you I've got depression here has
some oxycontin
they were pushing that [ __ ] like it was
[ __ ] candy to veterans you know we
had a huge opioid crisis addiction
crisis with our veterans that's why we
had so many goddamn suicides they
weren't getting treated for depression
they were given another [ __ ]
depressant on top of it
you know I mean and then instead of
wanting to deal with that crisis that
Republicans created of course they're
not going to sit there in a debate and
say yeah we kind of did this [ __ ] we're
the reason fentanyl's here they want to
turn around and say brown people brown
people did it be scared build the wall
you know like walls have worked since
what 1066 in the Battle of Hastings was
the last time a [ __ ] wall worked for
anything as the U.S does the U.S mail
have to go through the wall is that is
that to get the big home through I don't
know if that the U.S mail is actually
working on fixing this problem they know
they've got this problem
um
these are these are small packages right
these aren't yeah
it's it's in a small little package like
a like say this is jewelry or something
would be in
this is what is another problem that
they created when they when [ __ ]
Trump went to China and said you have to
make fentanyl illegal fentanyl in its
pure form is a hundred times more
powerful
than heroin
okay and wait a minute it's like a
thousand times more powerful than Aaron
and heroin 100 times more powerful than
oxy I mean it's just incredibly in its
pure form incredibly powerful and they
will mail a package the side I mean this
big I mean you saw the picture of those
packages They seized that's in the back
of a pickup okay these are small
packages these are not this is the ones
right these are not huge packages you
can mail that and that's cut fentanyl
right there that's not pure
that's cut fit no right there a pure
package of fentanyl is so freaking small
and something you said earlier about
fentanyl can't kill you you must open a
package of pure Fentanyl and you're not
wearing a resuscitator and a bunny suit
it will drop you instantly right but
what they're saying the lie that they're
telling because this is this is the
propaganda that they do they use a
kernel of truth right and they act like
this is because they did this with hot
they're doing this with Halloween candy
and I know why they're doing it with the
Halloween because it's in the lead-up to
the election right right and and I've
even seen I think it was good liars had
a video where a woman was like yeah
these and I think we showed it on the
show didn't we Gabe where's she's like
yeah these illegals are coming across
the country are coming across the border
in our country they're gonna set up and
hand this stuff out to for free two
children to kill them I I it it doesn't
make any sense like at all well if I I
can throw one more thing out there
that's just a real kick in the nuts
about this we know the Cato Institute
and you know guys I don't agree with the
Cato Institute I don't agree with them
they they tell the audience the Cato
Institute is first the Cato Institute is
a Libertarian Institute that's why I
don't agree with them very much but they
are honest okay I will tell you this
they will take and look at a situation
and they will give you accurate 100
facts
but their suppositions from those facts
I don't agree with because I'm not a
Libertarian I don't think taxes are a
crime I don't think that the
government's evil I don't think you know
our currency is a fiat currency all the
[ __ ] that Libertarians believe I I don't
believe that potato doesn't lie about
their facts and they have taken a look
at you know who's smuggling by who gets
arrested and prosecuted
they they looked at the numbers
over 85 percent are Americans
and it's not they're driving that [ __ ]
across the border in their [ __ ]
pickup trucks it's not what it is it's
really not that is a small small
fraction of the fentanyl trade it's
[ __ ] Bubba in Cincinnati
getting his mail package
setting up his lab just like they used
to set up speed Labs rapping in this
[ __ ] house in plastic on the inside
and getting a [ __ ] bunny suit from
Breaking Bad
so he can cut the [ __ ] open without
stopping his [ __ ] heart
and they mix it uphill press you can buy
a [ __ ] pill press on Amazon people
you can buy a pill press on Amazon
an automated pill press I'm not even
kidding all he has to do is cut the
[ __ ] bag of fentanyl open mix it with
with you know they used to use back in
the day they would use that I just wanna
I just want to preface that this is not
an instructional video I just wanna this
is not this is not an instructional
video we're not doing and we will not
discuss why I know how this works either
so
no I'm just kidding I am just kidding
I'm just I read people I read okay
um he's read on how to set up a drug
exactly exactly
I I've never set one up in my life okay
that we know of
instead I know
an instruction video but here's the
thing though is is it's the lies about
fentanyl that we're talking about here
because the truth the truth is actually
very damning when you talk about
Fentanyl and what I mean by that is it's
destroying lives it's destroying lives
right and and the reason why it's
destroying lives is not because it's
it's fentanyl in particular but it's
because it's the easiest opioid now to
grab a hold of right like before and
heroin then it was Oxycontin and then
that went away now it's fentanyl right
and when we get rid of the fentanyl
problem we're still going to have an
opioid problem because this is the thing
we have health care problems in this
country this is stems from a health care
issue that's what this is this is a
health care issue and if we get on board
to fix this problem but it's the lies
from the Republican sign from this
debate so what were some of those lies
that were told last night in particular
of course I know they're going to be
recycled but can you recall exactly what
the lies were about Fentanyl and some of
these debates from the Republicans they
were who are you asking why either one I
don't either
Joey yeah I'm it's the exact same thing
we have to build the wall because our
Southern border is wide open Joe Biden
somehow without changing a single law
because the one law they tried to change
has been set aside by a judge uh and is
being adjudicated in the courts right
now so literally nothing's changed but
the policy of not caging kids
and and treat people like humans human
beings yeah that's the only thing that's
changed is that they insist that we
don't break up families we don't need
anything like that okay that's the only
change somehow Joe Biden opened the
southern border they shed it all night
last night Joe Biden opened our Southern
border
[ __ ]
[ __ ] it's the same [ __ ] law title
42 same law that was in place under
Trump
period they the Republicans blocked
uh every time the the Democrats tried to
put immigration reform in any Bill the
Republicans blocked it because they
wanted this for this election
they wanted us for this election they
wanted a
humanitarian crisis and that's why
border patrol agents will tell you if
you talk to them and you can talk to
them off the Record they will tell you
they don't need to be dealing with this
this is not a police issue this is a
humanitarian issue [ __ ] FEMA needs to
be down here not us
right I mean
they're law enforcement
yeah
cbp's law enforcement and they're
telling you you are trying to stop the
humanitarian problem with with the law
enforcement law enforcement solution and
it doesn't work it's not going to work
all it does is make a fat [ __ ] racist
somewhere up in Nebraska feel good
that's that that's all that does
I mean because
I was going to say is uh because I mean
you know Republicans love to run on this
this platform of we got to build the
wall build the wall build the wall we
got to separate we got to isolate we got
to make sure that no you know Mexicans
or Guatemalans or Venezuelans or whoever
they might be can come up to the
southern border which by the way you
know we've talked about it before on the
show
um
building a wall through the southern
border terrain is [ __ ] ridiculous if
you want to go build through the terrain
of mountains and what I mean like there
are photos but like literally we have to
leave this get this 20-foot Gap here
because we cannot build up on this
actual stone
uh mountainous range
but Republicans think that oh yeah we
could just we could just build a wall
through anything which is like I mean
yeah
[ __ ] fat dude in Nebraska right
Nebraska it's like well why can't you
build a wall hell i'll build a wall at
my field it just do you know what a
[ __ ] ecological disaster if they
actually did Build That Wall do you know
what kind of [ __ ] ecological disaster
that would be do you know how many
species don't give a [ __ ] about your
imaginary [ __ ] border
they don't see your map right and they
run back across back and forth across
that [ __ ] border I hunt on the
southern border folks let me tell you
there are Russian board there are feral
Hogs there are and feral Hawks will tear
the [ __ ] out of your fence in a
heartbeat they will they'll dig that
[ __ ] up in a heartbeat feral hogs in
Texas there's an overpopulation problem
right now
huge huge you can shoot it you can shoot
a wild pig anytime you want anywhere
it's yeah it's I mean if that if that
fucker's running through your
neighborhood you can shoot that [ __ ]
they really hey we have a huge Fair old
big problem down here uh because we had
a huge pig farmer down in South Texas a
long long time ago about 80 years ago
shut his operation down turned his pigs
out and now we have millions of pigs
running around South Texas but anyways
or something yeah it's almost like yeah
it's on and it's almost like they're
smarter you know after the border wall
though real quick because that's another
[ __ ] line that they say because the
administration right now is currently
struggling with fixing the [ __ ] [ __ ]
ass wall that Trump built because it is
a government mandate to protect its
property and its property is the [ __ ]
[ __ ] fence that [ __ ] Trump built and
he built it it will not staying up
garbage right it won't stay up but a lot
of it and it's not just the the animals
going across the borders the water the
[ __ ] water has taken a lot of these
these goddamn these goddamn um pieces of
fence out and the federal government is
struggling to keep these pieces of fence
up because they're mandated to do that
that's the thing about [ __ ]
government when you make a decision to
do something you have to commit to doing
it even if it's really [ __ ] dumb
right and Republicans do really dumb
[ __ ] in government to make government
even dumber that's what they do and
that's why this fentanyl thing is so
stupid because they have caused a lot of
the problems that that is that is the
market of Fentanyl and what I mean by
that it's people who are sick from dope
it is a sickness it is a health care
issue this is what it is it is not it is
not a crime issue it is not a [ __ ]
family issue or domestic issue it is a
[ __ ] Health Care issue that is what
it is frankly most of the addiction
starts from our health care System right
that's where the [ __ ] [ __ ] starts is
these people which is exactly why they
they want to say this [ __ ] which is
exactly why they want to say this [ __ ]
they are in bed with the pharmaceutical
companies who are responsible for
starting this [ __ ] crisis and they
want to divert and they want to point
across the border and and they said the
shittiest things about Mexico last night
and let me tell you something
Mexico should be [ __ ] they are pissed
at us to be quite honest with you they
really have you ever heard of Rio de
jiero
that y'all ever heard of that it's kind
of an expression down in Mexico it's
called The Iron River
you know what that is that's the flow of
[ __ ] guns from us to them
there's one [ __ ] Gun Store Wait wow
wow wow wait a second text Paul
everybody knows that [ __ ] doesn't flow
across the border that Direction come on
Texas Park you telling me that that we
caused the Border crisis by sending our
manufactured guns across the border
don't you accuse there's one
hard-working white American Gun Store
one [ __ ] gun store in the country of
Mexico one it is in Mexico City it is
run by the government they sell about 30
to 40 guns a day
period that's it it takes about three
months to do all the paperwork just to
be able to walk into that [ __ ] store
it's run by the the military
it's you cannot go down to Mexico and
just buy a gun at a gun store like you
can here they come across the border
they buy guns at guns shows here from
private individuals all these [ __ ]
AR-15s you hear about and this that and
the other well I tell you what bub is
doing he's buying a 600 piece of [ __ ]
AR-15 and he's shipping it to Mexico for
1500 bucks and that's what they don't
want to [ __ ] stop
that's why they want to talk about
everything coming this way and they want
to talk about violence in Mexico well
let me tell you the Mexican police are
goddamn tired of every time they have a
shootout they pick up a [ __ ] gun
it's you know and they trace it back to
the United States they're really [ __ ]
tired of that they're tired of getting
shot by our [ __ ] guns that's what
they're really tired of and they're
really tired of us running our mouths
about how terrible the people in Mexico
are when they're actually trying to do
something to stop violence and then
you've got Greg Abbott here who's making
it super [ __ ] easy for any idiot to
walk around if you are a goddamn cartel
member
you can walk around my state with a
[ __ ] AR-15 slung them across your
back and a cop can't ask you a goddamn
thing about it
wait wait are you saying are you saying
that cartel members are welcome in Texas
as long as they got a rifle slung over
their shoulder as long as they're buying
guns they are
and Greg Greg Abbott won't do a goddamn
thing about it not a thing I mean that's
bad for business that's bad for these
gun manufacturers that that own Greg
Abbott you know hook line zinker that is
really bad you got to make sure that the
flow of their product is across that
border otherwise why would you have Greg
Abbott as the governor in the first
place I mean yeah really Texas ball I
mean come on man you know that that's
why they're talking about that's why the
the Republicans are talking about uh
that one of them got caught on the tape
the other day I forget his name they
want to eliminate the ATF completely
eliminate the ATF that's why you're
seeing the surge in quote ghost guns
because way too often these guns down in
Mexico we're exporting our [ __ ]
problems Canada hates us for that [ __ ]
too
you know Canada regulates their gun
purchases man they do but people come
across the border they buy one throw it
in the trunk of their car and drive home
you know it's just [ __ ] insane you
can buy a gun have it mailed to a
[ __ ] dealer who's by the way the
dealer is some guy named Chad that lives
over on Mulberry Street that got his
[ __ ] FFL license who gets a gun
mailed to him from [ __ ] Texas and
then you show up and you sign on the
dotted line and Chad says are you sure
you're you yeah okay thanks and you
leave with your [ __ ] weapon man
[ __ ] you Jen
I mean it's ridiculous and they don't
want to have these [ __ ] conversations
so what do they do Mexicans extra
Mexicans they're doing it to us you got
to be scared the Mexicans they're doing
it to us [ __ ] man I put a tweet up
the other day and said yeah these are
the people that they say are invading
our country they're harvesting Tomatoes
you got a whole [ __ ] you got a guy
next to a damn
wagon that's 40 feet long chucking
buckets of tomatoes out there that was a
great one after the other one after the
other and I'm like yeah this is your
[ __ ] Invader this is the guy that's
taking your job you know [ __ ] right
it's a load of bulls and they did it all
night in debates last night all [ __ ]
night well I mean I mean that's that's I
mean that's we we know that's what they
do they will they will pass the blame
they will pass the buck that is how
Republicans operate in this country if
they caused a problem or they complain
about a problem they they then blame
somebody else you know especially if
it's someone who is not white right
anyone who doesn't look like them
they're an outcast they're an outsider
they're the problem you know they're the
ones who are causing this this poison
this cancer within our country which is
really the Republican party right so
again it's you have you have a group of
people who are just trying to to achieve
this American Dream who comes to this
country with the with the possibility of
opportunity and then we have a bunch of
white people who say well you know
especially people in the state of Ohio
or Kansas or whatever it might be in
this so we need to protect the southern
border from what from the state that's
below you I mean the problem there isn't
that problem that's for you that's
that's in relation to to Mexico you're
in not a target for them you are someone
who is irrelevant to them they don't
care about you they care about
themselves and their family they're not
coming in this country with free drugs
to hand out to kids they're not coming
to this country with guns to hand out to
other people that's not how this works
and again it's just the Republican Party
trying to create a you know a boogeyman
fake problem that they can fix which
they don't ever actually fix they just
again push it push it push and push it
when they make the problem even worse
you know you talked about big Pharma
earlier I don't know if anyone's seen
dope sick but like that gives you an
inside perspective I mean [ __ ] they even
talk about Rudy Giuliani being a [ __ ]
lobbyist for them and pushing their
their agenda and making sure that they
can get through the legal paths he was
one of the people that actually defended
uh those big Pharma companies when it
came to court so like if there's anyone
you should be blaming you've got to look
at the Republican party and big Pharma
and these people the gun manufacturers
and these other people like those are
the ones who are in bed together and
Chad and Chad [ __ ] Chad because
here's the thing about and here's the
thing about Chad real quick Texas ball
because Chad's got a stockpile of all
these weapons and he's gonna sell right
and he goes to the gun show and he's
selling these [ __ ] weapons to the
cartel to go across the border he knows
that and then he sells it to the white
dude coming up like hey man you better
buy your weapons I just sold a shitload
of weapons to the cartel and boy they're
gonna come and kill you so you better
get you a weapon I mean and that is lit
now they don't say it that way they're
like oh you better be scared him in
cartels boy they're really dangerous
they're arming themselves because I did
it wink
um but that's that's literally what is
happening it's at in some of these
states especially like Texas where there
is this problem with the border and
stuff coming across it but it doesn't
seem like there's much of a problem this
way as it is that way
the last thing I'll say in this is if
American lives are at risk guns drugs
whatever Republicans won't do anything
to actually prevent it no they don't
actually they are not pro-life they will
not prevent you the death the loss of
human life
if it means more money in their pocket
they'll turn a blind eye and you know
you got Greg Abbott pushing the NRA and
you've got other people pushing Big
Pharma at the end of the day as long as
it makes them money
not a problem especially if it means the
loss of human life American lives
foreign
let's talk about Chad for a second here
okay Mexico has one [ __ ] gun store
right one right
not counting [ __ ] Chad and all the
class three dealers that we have around
here okay I just did a Google for you
the little town I live closest to okay
has a population of 80 000.
all right I live out in the sticks guys
I do but the little town I'm closest to
how many gun stores do you think serve
Uptown of the population of 80 000. in
this in this immediate area I just
Googled gun stores near me
I I would not even dare to guess
I'm impressed that you were that close
I'm impressed it was 38. it was 38.
that's still insane but all right Mexico
has one gun store
my little [ __ ] town of 80 000 peoples
is serviced by 38. before you [ __ ]
count Chad
now Chad's not a registered gun store
right he's just a dealer
you know he just he can buy and sell
commercially legally
you know
we have a [ __ ] problem in this
country we do period and we're exporting
it to Mexico and they're sick of our
[ __ ]
they are
that's why Greg Abbott is being such a
dick to Mexico
I mean there are best trading partner
and Greg Abbott treats Mexico like [ __ ]
I mean he disrespects him at every turn
if you heard the you hear him last night
in the debates talking about it Mexico
and their [ __ ] crime problem and this
hadn't yet and we got to build us a wall
to keep them people out you know no you
don't no you don't have no idea how much
how much goods and really perishable
Goods to boot that comes across that
border every [ __ ] hour every hour
there are truckloads of goods coming to
this country
that we rely on in this country for
trade to make sure that that we have the
[ __ ] that we want to have when we want
to have it because that's the American
way my God you know them real cheap TVs
you buy those real cheap TVs you buy at
Walmart those are made in Mexico man
they are they make TVs they make car
parts no you can't tell the truth God
damn they make furniture they make I
mean they make all kinds of [ __ ] that
they they drive across the border before
you talk about even the major massive
agricultural trading partner that Mexico
is with us even before you talk about
that even before you talk about the fact
that they are our Workforce and our
agricultural
industry period
I mean in Georgia you know you had Brian
Kemp talking [ __ ] about how this exact
talking point that fentanyl you know we
don't have a border with Mexico but we
got a fentanyl problem because you know
that open border [ __ ] you got a
[ __ ] fentanyl problem because you've
got you know [ __ ] [ __ ] David in
Atlanta that's buying packages of
[ __ ] fentanyl from China oh it's Chad
having mailed to his house dad's selling
the guns and the fentanyl it's Chad dude
I'm telling you man it's just
the amount of [ __ ] and disrespect
that these people have because they know
they can say that they know they can say
it it's what their voters want to hear
their voters want to hear that same old
lie that that LBJ told if you tell the
lowest white man that he is better than
the highest black man you do not have to
pick his pockets he will turn his
pockets out for you and they know it
it's the same grift it's been going on
forever
they're telling you you wonderful
hard-working toothless bastards are way
better than all those Mexicans
and they want that's what they want to
hear right that's what they want to hear
and that's why this [ __ ] sells because
they know [ __ ] all about the Border
they've never seen it never been to it
never anything they don't want to travel
outside their [ __ ] County much less
go to another country for Christ's sake
you know what I mean Mexicans
Hispanics period whether they're from
Venezuela anywhere have a wonderful
culture of community and family and they
take care of one another you know what I
mean they do things like have one
[ __ ] gun store in the country you
know what I mean so that if you want to
hunt you can go to that one gun store
and pay 500 bucks for a shotgun that you
can buy here for 180 but
because they care about their people
they care about their people that's
Hispanics for you you know what I mean
but what are what do these people do in
these debates you're better than they
are you're better than they are we need
to build a fence to keep those people
out and it's a it's it just enrages me
man because I grew up with these people
these are my people
you know that you're talking [ __ ] about
these are my people you're talking [ __ ]
about [ __ ] you I know your people I know
what you're [ __ ] like
I go to [ __ ] monster truck rallies in
in in in I've got family in Omaha I go
to truck and tractor pulls I know what
you [ __ ] are like after you've had a
few beers
you know don't uh
you're talking to me I know you're
talking to me no man you know what it's
like in Missouri man these [ __ ]
little babies
let me tell you something about this um
it's this it's this uh white trash
mentality
right you go to White America
and I mean White America
where it's a little rural town and he
said a little town like 80 000 Jesus
crash ball that's a that's a big city to
some of us rule folks I grew up in a
little town I grew up in a little town
that has less than 3 000 people
now when you go to these little towns
and it is all white I mean all white
there is no way other than to just say
it out loud to be racist you can't you
can't commit a hate crime in a town
where there's all white people now what
but what happens in these towns is
there's classism
not racism it's classism in these white
towns and what happens is is the people
in the town decide who who are going to
be the lower of them now rather it's a
certain side of town you live on or a
certain place that you live or a certain
name that you have or certain place that
you work or who your family is it's
classism in these towns
and a lot of times in these towns they
even use racial slurs towards the white
folks that are lower quote lower class
and that's where this stuff stems from
exactly what you're saying is because
these people these politicians
especially but these people in power
they they know that Trump knew that
Trump knew that there was this this this
mechanism in in these rural white
communities he knew there was this class
as a mechanism in these communities he
knew that and he tapped into it and how
great would it be because let me tell
you something
in the county that I grew up in
the poorest of the poor people the
people who would support Trump [ __ ]
hate cops they [ __ ] hate cops they if
a cop came on their property by God they
just might shoot that [ __ ] a lot
of times the law enforcement won't even
go on property without several agents
with them or officers with them because
they know they could get in a fire fight
because these people hate law
enforcement they're the same people that
vote for Trump they're saying people
vote for these Republicans saying back
to Blue it doesn't make any sense it's
not supposed to make sense it is not
supposed to it's not but they don't care
because it's just what Texas Paul said
whatever they feel in the moment about
that in particular thing whether it be I
want a gun or I want to sell a gun
whatever I need to believe to do that
thing that's what I'm gonna believe and
I'll vote for anyone who's willing to
make sure that I can say that [ __ ]
because that's really what's going on
here they're trying to put people in
power to let them do whatever the [ __ ]
they want to do and by them I mean white
people why it's white supremacy through
and through this fentanyl [ __ ] when
you're [ __ ] because
I'm sure if you look up the statistics
of who's using fentanyl it ain't [ __ ]
Mexican people in America
it's not
that's not who's the majority that's
using [ __ ] fentanyl in this country
[ __ ] no they got to get up and go to
work next day man God damn right but
here's the thing here's the thing
they're they they can't come to grips
with with their poor white State having
problems with fentanyl because they had
to suck on the teat a big Pharma
and they had to make sure that people
didn't get actual [ __ ] Health Care in
a delivery system and access to it that
now they're in a situation where they
have to keep lying and lying and lying
and lying and blaming it on brown people
blame it on this blame it on that
besides blame it on the actual problem
which is [ __ ] Republicans and [ __ ]
Republican policy because they don't
give a [ __ ]
about these people so much so that
they'll just tell them what they want to
believe not actually give them the facts
not tell them what they need to do to
fix the problem they'll just keep lying
to them and lying to them and lying to
them just like Marsha Blackburn did with
fentanyl just like this morning she did
with college with college student debt
relief she's they're [ __ ] pieces of
[ __ ] and they'll continue to do it if
you let them and you the voter are the
one who can stop this nonsense you have
the power to stop this nonsense
this is exactly you're exactly right
Tony you're exactly right and back me up
on this game because I'm sure you saw a
lot of this too people are like how can
Hispanic Americans vote for Trump and my
answer is always Cesar may act remember
says I may act he's the guy that mailed
the pipe bombs oh yeah yeah that he was
living in a van outside his job at at an
auto parts store
and he was an avid Trump supporter
because Trump told Cesar mayak that he
was better than me
he's better than you he's better than
Gabe because they just switched the
[ __ ] labels around and made it
Republican and Democrat Maga and
liberals
and scissor mayak would do anything to
preserve that feeling that he got in his
miserable [ __ ] life
where he was living in his [ __ ] van
and you know [ __ ] washing in the sink
in the back of an auto part parts store
that he was better than me
that his contribution his hard work
that's the part we don't play Tony when
we when we pull Marjorie Taylor green up
and we play the stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] she
says
the part that we don't play
is what comes after that
where she tells her audience but you
you're America you're what keeps us
going you have to carry them they live
off your back they get [ __ ] for free
they don't want to work they're lazy you
work hard you're the American
and poor Hispanics hard-working
[ __ ] that have been here are
buying into it they are buying into it
I'm telling you it's a problem here in
Texas Hispanic males voting Republican
is a problem here in Texas and it is the
same [ __ ] song man
different labels that's all it is
no no I'm finished
no that was I was done then oh the only
thing I'll say to that is it is
as someone from the Hispanic Community
it does hurt to see people from
in some regard from the people that I
that I'm a part of to see them vote
Republican right because you might be
like oh well it could be Catholicism and
religion it could be just indoctrine
indoctrination it could also be the fact
that a lot of these people feel like
they need to belong right you're already
an outsider you come into a country that
already hates you
um The self-hatred Falls in you you feel
like you need to assimilate into our
culture and one of the things is you
gotta be uh anti you know non-american
right you need anti-immigrant even
though you yourself or your family might
have come from that right
and so
I know people who are like that and it
does for me it kills me inside to know
that they're voting against their own
best interests to know that they're
supporting a group of people who doesn't
who don't actually care about them right
we saw it with with Venezuela
Venezuelans seeking Asylum with um with
uh with DeSantis right we see the way
that Greg Abbott treats immigrants we we
treat these people who are seeking a
better life as just complete [ __ ] right
as political pawns as soon as as soon as
you serve the purpose or if you betray
the party or whatever you're done you're
out they don't give a [ __ ] who you are
as long as you move them forward to that
checkmate and that is what these people
are to them that's that's all they are
they're they're nothing more than an
object on a chess board that they need
to move around and you know if they need
to sacrifice you so be it
and so when I see people within my own
community
vote that way support those things say
those things I I very much throws me
off my game because it's not something
that I think would be inherently the way
that you would want to go especially
when Trump says you know in his his uh
announcement speech in 2015 he goes oh
all those Mexicans that come across the
border they're rapists and drug dealers
and criminals and all these things like
straight out of the gate just dog
whistle blowing it loud and clear and
there are still people
whether it's you know
um a a grooming or indoctrination or
they really do fear look I'm already an
outsider if I don't play by the rules of
what you're saying then I am now going
to be the target
and they're not considered they're not
you know they're not considered people
by Republican standards you know they're
they're a they're a piece of a person
not a full human being that that they
treat their fellow white person
um and yeah and like Tony said there's a
classism aspect as well like if you're
part of a class and you're better than a
lo you know it's [ __ ] up the way that
we live in this country and it's also
[ __ ] up that the way that we treat
other people
um and it's even more [ __ ] up that
there are people within the Hispanic
Community or the black community or the
Asian community that will die by the way
of the Republican party because they're
they are in my way I I look at their
betraying their own people they are they
are uh you know and uh
an enemy of of their own group because
they're not doing what actually would
benefit them they're doing the thing
that they'll you know in in this country
we learn that it's
you do what you need to do for yourself
and don't consider anyone else it's
isolationist and it's there's no group
mentality in there
so
I don't know yeah and you hit that right
on the head there's no group mentality
and the Republicans attack that they
pick at those cracks they pick at those
cracks incessantly they sell in the
Hispanic community's anti-black rhetoric
anti-asian rhetoric they and they they
tell but like you remember the the Biden
bus that got it oh the crazy bastard
yeah almost run off that road yeah
there's a guy by the name of Ellie I
went to school with that sumbitch
did you really yeah yeah I did I know
him his cousin is a friend of mine I I'm
not even kidding his cousin's a [ __ ]
Trumper to you man I tell you what I
[Music]
Eloy if you're listening God damn it Eli
but anyways uh Ellie
was [ __ ] nuts man and he and he
listened to that [ __ ] he listened to
these [ __ ] Texas Republicans man
talking [ __ ] about how blacks were
getting all the welfare and you know
Asians were treated so well out in
California and this that and the other
he [ __ ] turned into
a racist
he turned into a [ __ ] racist you know
and it was him they kept telling him the
same goddamn lie you worked so hard you
worked so hard and everybody else has it
so easy and they're taken from you and
they sing in this [ __ ] song to these
people and they do they divide
you know groups that should be tighter
than tight man
I mean I and they just divide them with
the same [ __ ] rhetoric well but
they've done it even I mean if you look
at the Second Amendment even they act
like this is some kind of individual
right like it's your your individual
god-given right like it's something that
only you have the right to to arm
yourself which that's not at all what
the Second Amendment says and this this
sickness of individualism in this
country because there is individualism
we should have the liberty of
individualism and I mean have the
liberty of it but not to be required and
mandated to have individualism because
that's what causes this classism because
folks what I just described in white
communities doesn't just happen in white
communities and it's the reason why is
because exactly what Texas Paul said
they like to drive those wedges into
cracks they continue it and this idea
that Hispanics don't have this well the
the dichotomy of hey well at least I'm
not as low as this person or in this
community they say well at least I'm not
as low as this person over there in that
Community or at least it it exists in
our country it exists in our DNA it
exists in us institutionally that's the
whole purpose and that's what they're
taking advantage of and they're taking
advantage of the lie because it's all
[ __ ] lies I mean it's all [ __ ]
lies it's just nonsense it's just
[ __ ] I mean us three we're all three
[ __ ] human and any other humans we
get on here they would be human I mean
maybe other than Ted Cruz Ted Cruz is
questionable just saying it really is
have you seen Ted Cruz he he might be a
lizard I'm just saying yeah he might be
a little he's a bit of a blob right but
here's the thing
is that as long as long as we let them
get away with these lies
little big or whatever because that's
how it starts and that's how they're
doing this is little by little by little
just these little lies here little lies
there little lies here little lies there
and they take advantage of what I called
earlier classism inside these
communities and they create it into this
problem where it's this community now
against this community now
um where it wasn't it's not that's not
near the truth and that's how we get to
the situation where they absolutely will
not do anything about the fentanyl
problem the actual fentanyl problem
meaning the health care problem of
fentanyl because that's the fentanyl
problem we have it's a health care issue
it's a health care
problem and only Health Care policy will
fix it that's it building a wall having
some kind of [ __ ] ban on this or ban
on that or something kind of you can't
ship it here or can't ship it there you
can regulate the [ __ ] out of it all you
want in the manufacturing process of
this stuff but if you don't fix the
[ __ ] Health Care problem people are
going to seek out the opioid they're
going to because the problem is the
health care problem we have derived from
opioids I hate to tell you that I hate
to say it like that but that's that's
the issue that we have that's the issue
and we're dealing with it with this in
the stupidest way possible too you know
in Portugal they decriminalized all
drugs they do decriminalized all this I
didn't say they made them legal and said
hey you can smoke heroin on the street
and [ __ ] like no they just
decriminalized
if you have a drug problem meaning they
don't lock you up in a jail
if you are an addict
they will put you in treatment you will
keep your job
you will not go to jail and be a drain
on the Portuguese Portuguese people you
will keep your [ __ ] job
you'll go to work you'll take care of
your family and they will give you
treatment for your addiction if you're
an addict and you know what else they
found out
this [ __ ] isn't as addicting as we they
portrayed it to be that [ __ ] coming out
of the Reagan that that whole [ __ ]
Reefer Madness [ __ ] was [ __ ]
only 10 percent of people that use [ __ ]
and I'm not [ __ ] preaching using
drugs people don't do it don't do it
because you could be one of the one in
[ __ ] ten but only ten percent of the
people they did a study a real study
only 10 percent of the people that
utilize heroin became addicted
most didn't even want to use it again
because they didn't like the entire I
don't get drunk a lot guys because I
don't like the feeling of intoxication
that doesn't do it for me I don't like
being intoxicated
you know I don't I don't like that
feeling of being out of control is that
what you is that what you prefer Texas
ball I mean you can be honest with us
you know I may I may go to uh you know
Colorado every once in a while
you're going hunting it's a hunting trip
right exactly we love cutting in
Colorado yeah just the fact that it's
not hunting season I'll ignore that
right right well you're hunting
yeah yeah hunting Bear yeah there you go
I like that I'm gonna use that for going
unbear
but you know
Portugal has been wildly successful with
this
but our law enforcement industry and
it's an industry in this country doesn't
want that they scream every time they
talk about legalizing marijuana because
it is the number one thing that they use
to Parlay into other crimes
you know he didn't get out of his car
fast enough so I had to yank him out of
his car and when I yanked him out of his
car he grabbed a hold of my shirt and
that is you know that's another charge
right there you know you and now the
private prison industry has has somebody
that they can hold for six months and
make money off of and you know his
family's [ __ ] over and and and now
he's got an arrest on his record that
officer gets a notch on their belt and
then they can get another notch and
another notch and another notch and how
easy it to get notch on belts for Gummy
Bears
um yeah I think that well
the one thing I want to add to that is
like you know textball brings up a point
about just treating and you know again
we've talked about this before is like
treating humans like humans right having
empathy which is something that the
Republican Party lacks uh to its [ __ ]
core whether it's knowing how to design
apps or just treating people like people
right there was a lack of empathy that
the Republican Party has in in
addressing or approaching anything
they're trying to solve or any problem
or just anything in life right and this
is an example where you would say oh
yeah cool this person they got addicted
and we're gonna help treat them
to get them better right to get them
back on their feet to get them back in
their home to get them back at work
right to actually uh contribute to our
economy in our community instead of
saying well you're a drug addict and
you're now been stigmatized and you're
now homeless and now you don't have a
family and now you lost your job and now
you have this like all of these things
and then the Republican party goes well
you're just a lazy drug addict and
that's all you are and that's what the
and that's what those people see and
it's like no wonder people
you know do more drugs or commit suicide
or whatever it is right you've got a
group of people
who just berates them down and down and
down and says that you're not worthy
you're not good instead of saying hey
look we might have [ __ ] you over with
this problem by introducing these drugs
and not regulating the market and not
actually having a system in place to
help you
they say ah you can go [ __ ] yourselves
which is like again what Republicans do
for any problem or any issue instead of
actually saying oh you're a fellow human
I would want the same courtesy on myself
if I was going through the similar
problem as you are but instead they go
you're lazy you're a drug addict you're
this you're this you're this you're this
so just give you labels and labels and
labels but then that person is like well
I guess then all I am is what you say I
am and and then you obviously see that
the worst results possible because
you've just abandoned your fellow
you know Community member Christian you
know whatever you want to call it but
that is what Republicans will do and
they'll just say
see ya
and that's why the freest country on
Earth has has more people locked up in
prison than anyone else in the world we
lead the world in the number of people
that we've taken their freedom from and
because of exactly what you're talking
about Gabe because you hit it right on
the damn head when we were faced with a
problem when when communities I'm
talking about black communities I don't
I don't know if you guys are old enough
to remember Cabrini Green up in Chicago
yeah yeah you're from Chicago yeah
they took a look at that problem and
there were two ways they could have went
they could have went the way that that
historically we know worked which was
when they ended prohibition
the [ __ ] gangsters stopped being
violent
they could have ended the violence that
way or you can
Ultra
police this and make it Ultra illegal
and come up with harsher you know three
strikes in their out rules and and and
[ __ ] like that and you can dump a [ __ ]
ton of money into ruining people's lives
for using drugs and guess which way we
went
and it was the African-American
communities it was you know it was the
black communities it was the Hispanic
communities that were telling people you
have to do something about this we got a
violence problem we've got to drive by
far I don't know if you all know about
the 80s and the 90s
you know [ __ ] people shooting like
this I mean if you think hillbillies are
bad with guns you ought to see drug
dealers with guns Jesus Christ man you
know I mean and the worst the worst part
about that you bring Cabrini Green and
it really goes to show you which is like
certain policies in place in in the
mentality we have towards how to solve
these problems is uh it was in two when
I was I graduated high school and they
were beginning the demolition of caprini
green and so I can tell you that it's
you know there's a 30-year cycle where
you have these empty nesters they move
into the city they move out and their
solution was hey instead of actually uh
providing a solution or an alternative
to what Cabrini Green should be uh we're
now going to ship you out to the suburbs
and we're going to demolish this and
we're going to build a Target or the
shopping center and a bunch of condos
instead over this area that we gave you
uh and I mean I I would I I watched it
growing up as a kid and then I witnessed
the demolition of this and coming back
to Chicago I see people displaced from
their homes not having a place to go
then you have this this hyper uh you
know this gentrification and also
polarization of wealth between two
groups that once was there as as Section
8 housing or low income housing and then
you have this group of you know young 20
30 year roles who are now living in
these high rises as as a as as a
replacement and so it's whether it's the
policing but then once the problem gets
too bad and you're like well this is
great real estate they say all right you
guys got to go and they don't offer them
an actual solution
yeah yeah I mean exactly exactly what I
was saying the the the solutions that
they come up with and and this was
during the Clinton Administration when
this happened it was you had the Clinton
Administration appeasing the black
community
with these radical law enforcement
policies that created help create this
massive prison industry we have today
because it was the wrong damn thing to
do because
why and why am I going to end up playing
blaming Republicans for this because
every goddamn Republican who's running
on Law and Order every goddamn
Republican was running on get tough
selling this [ __ ] so if Democrats
ran on well you know what let's just do
make this not illegal and we'll give
them treatment and this that and the
other you seem like a pansy and you lose
your [ __ ] election because
[ __ ] bright up in Nebraska scared of
them people you know he's gonna vote for
that [ __ ]
and I'm telling you cookouts cookouts is
how we fix this [ __ ] I I know it sounds
like a goddamn joke but I'm telling you
the truth we have become an isolated
people
we sit in our houses I sit out here in
my freaking woods man I force myself to
go interact with people so that I can
keep in touch and keep that you
we have gated communities where people
literally Drive in their gated community
drive into their garage shut their
garage door they do not talk to their
neighbors they don't know their
neighbors they don't know what's going
on they barely see the kids you know
Friday Night Football used to be a
social event man you go to one now
nobody talks
no one talks to each other they sit they
face forward when something good happens
they go yay when something bad happens
they go boom and that's it
they don't speak to each other anymore
and [ __ ] cookouts will fix that man
I'm telling you you spend time I went to
an event for uh you know I always help
out Democratic groups I do I all the
time I went to an event and one of the
groups there was the first
transgender transgender gender
motorcycle gang
they call themselves The Factory Rejects
I'm not kidding it's a transgender
motorcycle game
and you cannot hang out with those
people because after about five minutes
you forget their transgender people and
they're just people right and they had
the coolest freaking dog there man this
Doberman was gorgeous and I was like I
wanted a pet can I pet that dog
I want to do so bad but that dog would
not warm up to me at all but and I don't
know why dogs normally love me but you
don't you hang out with people and all
of a sudden they're not the other
anymore
and that's how we fix it man that's how
we fix it we have got to get people not
just packed into a stadium where they're
not freaking talking to each other Texas
Paul I'm gonna be onto something here
hang on a second I think you're on to
something I'm running out of time but I
think what we should do is have Liberty
cookouts I think he's on to something
here audience I mean just have Liberty
cookouts everywhere make this a [ __ ]
thing make this a culture where we
invite everybody anybody and anybody
wants to come to cookout by God come to
the cookout because there's nothing
there's nothing better than food to get
people together to get them talking and
to get them laughing well actually
I was thinking about game
what do you think about the adopt a
white boy program
[Laughter]
I mean honestly you could you could you
could bring a lot of change you br you
bring a white boy into a home especially
that of a culture you know oh my God the
seasons they will have the the the types
of food Tapas like all around I mean
just the the
you know I think there is something
where it's like oh I'm gonna have a
study abroad student come over I'm going
to adopt a white boy and just help them
understand what the [ __ ] is going on in
this country and the real people that
are here and understand the culture I
totally agree I think that's a real
thing that we should do okay well let's
I am not kidding Gabe I am not kidding
because white people are scared they're
gonna invite a black guy over and it's
going to be the quietest [ __ ] dinner
you ever had and there's going to be
mayonnaise as a seasoning you have an
adopt a white boy program you have an
adopt a white boy program and you take a
white boy out of the burbs and you bring
them into the hood and you show them
some real barbecue and you show him some
music and people out there dancing
having a good time drinking a few beers
next thing you know
everybody's living in a gentrified
neighborhood white boys I'm just kidding
I'm just kidding
I gotta I've gotta end it Texas Paul
this is supposed to be a 30 minute thing
and every week it gets longer and longer
I'm super excited about it I'm happy
about this the audience loves it we love
having you here every single Tuesday uh
tell them tell them where they can go to
find your YouTube channel
next week you cannot I have to make an
announcement I'm doing some traveling I
always keep it real and I do what I do I
really support things and you're gonna
love what I do next week but the next
week I will be out there will be no
shows but you can find me on Sunday
afternoon competing with the Sunday
shows with Sunday coffee with Texas Paul
you can find me on uh on Wednesday
evenings it used to be Wednesday
evenings we're moving to Tuesdays and
Thursdays immediately following the uh
the Midas touch podcast or TN Tennessee
Brando and I do TNT we're going to do it
on Tuesdays and Thursday evenings but
not next week next week I've got some
things going on and you're going to love
the footage when I get back and I want
to thank Jen for mailing me the
California republic shirt she was you
know where there was a conversation
where people were trash talk in Texas
and I had to explain to them that that
Texas is not all the stereotypes you
hear that they're more people like me
than there are people like Greg Abbott
and [ __ ] walleye Paxton and all those
people and the Houston is the most
diversity in the country
and by the end of the conversation he
got in touch with Miss Texas Mrs Texas
Paul got our P.O box and mailed me a
California Republic shirt and I'm
wearing the [ __ ] out of this thing I
love it I love this shirt I love it so
everyone go follow Texas Paul on on
YouTube just go to his link tree I think
it's link tree slash Texas Paul isn't it
just go to link link tr.e Texas Paul
that's right so go to Texas Paul
linktree find all the links there for
social media Texas Paul until next
Tuesday I'll stay in the chat with you
my friend
I'm telling you let's do it man we'll
start we'll start a GoFundMe and adopt a
white boy program
you know we'll get families
we'll get black families Hispanic
families Asian families to adopt
middle-aged white boys that are you know
and bring them out for the cookouts and
the next thing you know
I mean the only way to break to break
generational racism right is to is to
smash It smash it with some barbecue
right that's it smash it with some
culture smash it with some food smash it
with something that's it that's it
thanks thanks for joining us everyone
stick around we'll be right back for a
little bit of [ __ ] let's round up just a
little bit right after this break we'll
we'll stick around we'll be right back